-Our next guests
are Ramy Youssef,
the Golden Globe-winning creator
and star of "Ramy,"
currently in its second season
on Hulu,
and Patrisse Cullors,
political strategist,
co-founder of Black Lives Matter
and founder of
Reform L.A. Jails.
Here is our conversation.
Ramy and Patrisse, thank you
so much for joining us today
Now, Ramy, we had you booked
to talk about the second seaso
of your fantastic show, "Ramy,
on Hulu,
and with the time
we're living in,
you asked if you could bring
your friend Patrisse,
who is a co-founder of
the Black Lives Matter movement.
And I was just wondering how you
two met in the first place
-Patrisse and I met on --
We were on a ship, right,
Patrisse?
-Yes. We were on a ship,
on a cruise ship.
-Like a boat?
-Yes.
-I was doing comedy
on a cruise ship.
You know comedy.
You know how comedy works.
-Sure.
-You know the places
comedy can bring you.
But we were part of a really
cool thing called Summit Series.
So we met there
and instantly just became fans
of each other's work.
And like you said, obviously
it's a weird thing
to promo a show while
these things are going on,
and it felt really excitin
to bring Patrisse on
to talk about the amazing work
she's been doing for so long
-I understand, Ramy, obviously
it is hard to promote anything
in these times, but your sho
does deal with heavier issue
than maybe most sitcoms
would deal with.
You actually have an anti-
or I should say
you have a racism episode
about the fact that not
just whites are racist
in this season of your show.
-Yeah, it's a theme
that we definitely explore
I think there is this dialogue
that racism is like white people
versus people of color.
And I think part of what
we're seeing right now
is under the "people of color"
umbrella,
there are a lot of forms
of anti-blackness that go on
You know, like, white people are
definitely the best at racism.
Like, they're doing it on,
like, a professional,
you know, like, NBA level.
But I do think that there ar
other groups in there
where you're like,
"Oh, you guys are --
You're playing, like,
some EuroLeague racism.
Like, you wish you could
be in the NBA."
And I really feel like calling
that out in our own community.
So for me looking at it,
of course,
in my own communities wher
the anti-blackness is,
but, you know, as much as we
can really look at that
and examine ourselves
instead of making the argument
really binary.
-So, Patrisse, you started
Black Lives Matter
after the murder
of Trayvon Martin.
And obviously,
what we're seeing, you know,
this week and last week
is violence is still happening
against black people,
young black people.
But do you feel positive about
how much the movement's grow
in the years since
that first started?
-Sure. I mean, you know, first I
just want to send a lot of lov
and condolences to so many black
people who lost their live
at the hands of law enforcemen
and vigilantes.
So much of our work is about
not just black death,
but the fight for black life
And right now we're in a momen
where the entire country -
and I argue the entire world -
is trying to reevaluate it
relationship to black people
and how much we're standing up
for black people
and how much we're fightin
for black people.
And I think my hope lies
in the very people
who are on the streets,
the people who I call essentia
workers for black life.
We're not just protesters.
We're working for black life
We're working to make sure tha
our children get to grow u
in a society where they're
not murdered or gunned dow
in their own neighborhoods o
in other people's neighborhoods.
I have a lot of hope right now
even amidst the grief
and the rage I feel.
-The protests have been
overwhelmingly peaceful,
but there is a media focus
on looting.
Obviously, that makes for very
you know --
I don't want to say
good television,
but it feels like it ends up
on television a lot.
And you were frustrated
by the fact
that oftentimes someone
like yourself,
someone who is supportive
of the protests,
has to answer for the looting.
How can people speak about
that element of it better,
or what are the questions
you would prefer to be asked
-Great question.
I think -- And what I'm ofte
describing to people
is we are very obsessed
with property damage.
Property damage is seen as
sort of like the pinnacle
of destruction and violence.
And we rarely hear the media
focus on police violence
or police terror.
For example, Saturday,
many of us were out protesting
across the country, me included.
I was at a protest
in Los Angeles
up at 3rd and Fairfax,
and it was peaceful
for two hours.
And then the police showed up,
and it was no longer peaceful.
The police tear-gassed folks
They beat up people.
And it was unprovoked.
And so there's this conversation
that I think is an uneven
conversation in the media
about people who are looting
versus the infrastructure
and the structure of racis
and the police officers
who continue to cause havo
and chaos in our communities
-Ramy, you have been at some
of the protests visually,
and you have some pictures
we can share right now,
because your billboard
is up for the new show.
And let's be honest, you avoided
what could have been a lot worse
based on show billboards
I've seen in the past.
-Yeah. I mean, it's --
Yeah, I've gotten a lot
of photos from close friends
and I went myself, too.
And I was like,
"Man, this is a really --
I'm so happy we didn't pic
the picture of me smiling.
There was, like,
a big talk with marketing.
They're like, "No, you shoul
be smiling on the billboard.
You know, it would
look more inviting."
And I'm so glad
it's just that look down,
because it would be
kind of sinister
if I was smiling over everything
that's happening right now
-Yes.
-But yeah, yeah.
-That would have been
the rare case where you --
It wouldn't have been
marketing's fault,
because you just
wouldn't have known
how bad a look
it would have been.
I also want to talk
about this idea
which I think people believe
to be radical,
which is when you hear
an activist
talk about the idea
of defunding the police.
But it is a less radical ide
than maybe people would jump to,
because it's not going fro
the current police budget
to no police budget.
Could you just speak to
what that terminology mean
and why most people
would probably agree with it
-Sure.
If anybody has time, they should
look up their city budget.
It's public.
And what they'll come to realize
across every major city --
and I argue small cities,
as well --
is that the majority
of the budgets
are made up of police,
of law enforcement,
as a law enforcement budget.
And what we start to realize
so much
in our communities
that are divested from,
that have little access
to healthcare,
educational opportunities,
access to jobs and healthy foo
is that our city governments
are using our tax dollars
to primarily pay for an econom
of punishment
over an economy of care.
And that's what so many
Black Lives Matter organizer
and organizers that are allies
of Black Lives Matter
are asking for is to allow for
a reallocation of investment
into some of
the most marginalized
and divested-from communities.
-Ramy, I know you've been doin
comedy for a very long time.
Did you ever feel like even when
you talk about the issues
that you're helping?
-I think really the most
that I could do
or a show like mine could do
is emotionally prepare peopl
to face the questions
that they have.
I really don't think that comedy
is supposed to give answer
or that the work
can give answers,
but I think a lot of us
have questions
that we're afraid
to ask ourselves.
And I always hope that the wor
can bring people closer
to those questions
and closer to facing the thing
that they need to.
But to me, the real change comes
from people like Patrisse,
people who are out there,
who are not only protesting,
but they're looking
at legislation
and they're organizing
and they're really
getting people together.
So I think if we can on our en
in making things
help emotionally prepare people,
it's a good part of the process,
but it's hardly the kind
of change that, you know,
someone who I admire so much
like Patrisse, is doing
and has been doing
since she was 15.
-And so how many years
into activism
and organizing are you,
Patrisse?
-21 years.
I've been doing it for 21 years.
-How did people first reac
to you when --
I guess you must have
been a teenager,
as Ramy said, when you first
started taking this on.
-My friends thought
I was strange,
but that's not uncommon for me
I was, like, not the --
I was always kind of the strange
kid doing my own thing.
So they would come with me
to events,
because, you know,
friend groups,
and I would be like, "Alright.
They'd be like,
Let's go do this thing."
I'd be like, "Well,
let's go to this march,
or let's go to this meetin
about activism
and the transit system
in Los Angeles."
And we would be the youngest
people in the meeting
with, like, 50-year-old folks,
and my friends would be like
"Yo, this is not it.
This is not it, Patrisse."
But I promise you,
when I started Black Lives
Matter seven years ago
and when we were first
on the streets,
one of my good friends
who makes fun of me the most
she called me and said,
"I get it now.
I get why you've been doing this
for like 16 years.
Like, I'll show up
to one of your protests."
So, yeah, I've always done this.
My father --
You know, one of my father
would tell me that I grew up
in the wrong generation.
He was like, "You were suppose
to be born in the '60s or '70s
'cause clearly, you missed it.
This is not your time,"
but then we created it.
We created a new movement,
and I'm so grateful for that
-You know, obviously,
you want --
I think we all want
to be optimistic
of what will come with this,
but you know, I do think it'
important that our sadness
our anger, our frustration
about what happened
to George Floyd remains.
Ramy, could you just speak
to what Islam teaches
about forgiving?
-Yeah, this is something
that we talked about a bunch
which is in Islam
kind of talking about,
what is the human's
biggest problem?
And it's not that
we're bad people.
It's that we're forgetful,
that we forget.
And so so much of our faith is
about, how do we remember God?
How do we remember
our higher selves?
How do we stay connected
to the principles
that we know make us good
and the ones that we know
help us serve humankind
and serve ourselves in way
that, you know, surpass the ego.
And I think so much of this is
challenging the ego of society
challenging the supply chain
of how we get things,
challenging the way we loo
at human life,
and it's almost
like something like
what's happening outside
right now.
It's not radical in the sens
that no one's heard about this
It's just us being like,
"Oh, man, we forgot, you know.
We forgot again."
You know, we keep forgetting
and we really need
to step into that.
And again, it's why the work
that Patrisse has been doing
is so important.
-Well, I want to thank you bot
for being here.
Ramy, thank you so much fo
the introduction to Patrisse
I hope the next time I see
both of you, it's in person.
And please do be safe out there.
-Thank you so much, Seth.
-Thanks.